closing arguments are expected today in
the double murder trial of disgrace
South Carolina lawyer Alec murdaugh
before that happens jurors will visit
the scene of the crime the Murdoch
family's Moselle property Nikki Batiste
is covering the trial in Walterboro
South Carolina
I mean this is a process that's got to
stop at some point we're going to be
here next week Alec murdahl's defense
team complained Tuesday as prosecutors
called a new witness and brought back
several old ones among them the
disgraced attorney's former law partner
have you angry at him for stealing your
money I have no feeling one way or the
other prosecutors also pushed back
against the defense's theory that there
was more than one shooter calling crime
scene expert Kenneth Kinsey to testify
can you exclude two shooters
I cannot include or exclude two Shooters
can the defense include to the exclusion
of all other possibilities two Shooters
absolutely not Kinsey called the
defense's portrayal of how the murders
happened quote Preposterous there is no
room in the prosecution's case for a
second shooter CBS News legal analyst
Ricky cleeman says the defense's
two-shooter theory could create
Reasonable Doubt for jurors who are
expected to visit the crime scene this
morning a jury view can be of
extraordinary Advantage they want to
place the jurors in that kennel I
certainly would want them to walk
through the house having to do with the
amount of steps that Alec Murdoch walked
after the alleged killings took place
according to the prosecution
after their visit to the crime scene the
jury will come back to the courtroom
this afternoon and closing arguments
will get underway the prosecution will
go first followed by the defense and
then the prosecution will have an
opportunity for rebuttal Gail
all right still a lot more to do thank
you Nikki